called what Christian Europeans or the
emergence of Christian Europe 600 to
1200 is not a single word of that series
that everybody could agree on either
that should be a topic or that it was
the best label for the topic and so it
we simply adopted it it's the point at
which the book begins to overlap a
certain tradition of Western Civ not the
Western Civ of the 1950s but rather the
Western Civ of the earlier 20th century
this is a copy of the syllabus for
history one at Harvard University circa
1931 the title of the course was
European history from the fall of the
Roman Empire to the present time and the
last chapter deals with World War one
it is a syllabus of the sort that no one
does anymore
better say it has several pages of
instructions on how to take notes how to
think about authors and so forth and so
on but what it what it also reflects is
a view that was very common in that
generation earlier that Western
civilization begins in the aftermath of
the fall of Rome as opposed to the
Western Civ textbooks of the 50s and 60s
that started with River Valley
civilizations and went through Greece
and Rome and then picked up the story of
Europe the story of Europe was seen
as coherent an autonomous narrative that
warranted being the first and foremost
subject of a college history curriculum
hence the sense label history one the
reasons for that are not hard to seek
there was certainly a an assumption in
that era that Western civilization
meaning Ural American civilization was
the pinnacle of human achievement and
was pointing the way and big fat neon
well maybe not in 31 but big fat you
know letters toward the future and to
some degree when you added Greece and
Rome and the early Egyptian and
Mesopotamian civilizations to it that
that focus began to become diluted and
people began to think well really what
does Alexander the Great have to do with
Europe his conquests were mostly in Asia
or what does what those Sumerians have
to do with Europe even if they did think
up the idea of 360 degrees in the circle
so the story of Europe for such a long
time held pride of place then it began
to to dwindle but when we do world
history today in virtually every
textbook I would say when he do
narrative world history as opposed to
simply comparative studies on this earth
at dimension of world history or and
this or that theme going to narrative
world history at some point the the
European story takes on a special sort
of a special character
and it gets reasserted in chapters
you're much more likely to have the
European chapters be freestanding just
Europe alone as opposed to comparative
or devoted to contact with other areas
at least up to the point of the voyages
of exploration in the 15th 16th
centuries now another approach to things
and that's that's an old the old
European you know the old special role
for Europe approach another approach
that I want to mention here is one that
comes out of social science particularly
political science and economics and this
is the idea of half dependence or path
dependency you can use either term when
you examine the evolution of something
and by evolution here I mean the
development over time of an institution
of a economic structure of a social
configuration of a political ideology
when you look at these things over time
what certain social scientists have
asked but not generally historians is
whether it could have come out
differently if you believe that it could
not have come out differently then you
are arguing that the variables that
appear in the historical narrative
wouldn't really have changed much of
anything on the other hand if you say
that those variables those specific
actions or events
in fact could have gone in other ways
and changed everything then you're
talking about path dependence and yours
you're saying that the the subjectivity
of your look that you're looking at
depends upon the particular path that
that events took and sometimes I
referred to as the theory that history
matters now historians always a thought
the history mattered and so they tend to
take umbrage at the idea that you might
say that history doesn't matter on the
other hand there are cases to be made
that the that there are events or
changes that occur that are going to
have outcomes that really are more or
less independent of the of the
particulars of the events or responses
to the events say an obvious one is if
you have a pandemic that removes half
your population you're going to have a
fall in agricultural production now that
fall may be managed in different ways it
may manifest itself in different ways
but you're going to have it because
you've taken away so much labor and
taking away so much demand that that is
going to happen now this is in the sense
self-evident as so much of what
political scientists and economists do
is but they there is a propensity in
those disciplines to take particular
case studies and say look this happened
therefore this had to happen
therefore this had to happen therefore
this had to happen and two-string
essentially inevitabilities along and
say this was necessarily the outcome
you have a great deal of discussion
today about the financial crisis and
whether given you know say deregulation
that inevitably it was going to result
in a in bubbles the bubbles were
inevitably going to burst everybody was
going to be unemployed they're being
miserable and Happiness and Sarah Palin
would become president and you could say
well this really is not path-dependent
except the Sarah Palin part um this is
simply what what was scripted because of
the nature of it and when you read
particularly Keynesian economists who
who say you know we can just see you
know the rates of this and that and how
they develop and we can see that this
had to happen the way it did happen and
it doesn't depend that much upon the
particular path okay now for European
history what has happened is that
leaving aside what seems to be obvious
namely that a whole lot of things
happened in Europe and that surely if
they'd happen differently we would have
come out differently nevertheless you do
have the notion that that Europe went
through a series of of changes and that
those changes constitute a template and
that that template is something that can
be transferred to other parts of the
world in other words if you have a
church and a middle-class and such and
such then they will lead to liberal
revolutions then they will lead to
democracy then you will lead to the the
triumph of big business or whatever so
that when people have dealt with
European history rather unconsciously
they have implied often that what
happened in Europe had to happen that
way
you didn't really have you know this is
just the way it had to go some people
would say well that's you know they had
to go that way because they were
Europeans they were you know brighter
and whiter and you know had more
testosterone than the other people in
the world except the women in Europe who
we don't care about and and that
therefore it's it's a question of racial
racial outcome and clearly that is an
outworn idea now except among a very
substantial proportion of the population
so so there are there ways of explaining
the problem there of course is that how
do you use the European template to
shift to other parts of the world and of
course one of the answers is you declare
other parts of the world to be honorary
white people as the Japanese became even
before the Meiji Restoration in the
1850s
the Dutch and Indonesia recognised the
Japanese as European whites
because the Japanese had recognized the
Dutch as people whom they permitted to
do business in Japan and the most
favored nation concept meant that if the
Japanese recognized the Dutch the Dutch
had to offer a an equal recognition so
he had this odd thing that you know
Ottomans citizens and Indonesia under
the Dutch were listed as Eastern
foreigners whereas Japanese and
Indonesian were listed as European
whites all right I wanted to sort of
take alternate two different approaches
this week today I want to talk about the
peculiarities of Europe and then on
Thursday I want to talk about a
situation in which you might argue and
indeed I would argue that things happen
in Europe that had to happen the way
they did regardless of the peculiarities
and then the question is that if you
have a mix of both path-dependent
developments and let's say developments
for which one can argue that there is a
applicable you know logic that follows
the rationality
that could conceivably of a political
science or the economists that could
conceivably reduce to be reduced to an
equation can you have it both ways can
you say Europe is is special and at the
same time Europe does what you know what
any society under those circumstances
would do and then in the following week
I will raise the test case of China in
the medieval period which is now one of
the hottest and most discussed
comparisons in world history you know
whether or not China in the in the
immediate pre Mongol period was not only
equal to but superior to Europe
according to various economic measures
that have so frequently been used to
indicate the special condition of Europe
all right
one of the first things you get to is
what is Europe the chapter title says
Christian Europe
well it says Christian Europe because
Spain and Portugal weren't part of it
but Russia does become part of it and so
now you're setting Europe as far east as
Russia perhaps at a time when Russia was
a pretty wild frontier of Slavic
villagers and farmers exploited by
Swedish warriors who came down the
rivers from the north and set up
principalities that like that but you
have the situation of the Byzantine
Empire some somewhere you have to
discuss the Byzantine Empire you discuss
discuss it with Rome which makes it very
difficult to compare Rome with the Han
Dynasty in China because the business
empire is the later Roman
hire the boson p.m. the low Empire and
but that starts around 300 or so and
this chapter is supposed to start around
so the first a had the first eight
mentioned is 332 because immediately it
proved impossible to write the chapter
without overriding the chronological
limits for the chapter but not like that
but the heart of the business being
Empire was not in Europe
in fact the capital of the Byzantine
Empire was just barely in Europe on the
what is today Istanbul Constantinople on
the Golden Horn which is on the European
side of the Bosphorus separating Europe
and Asia Minor or Anatolia so you start
out you know oddly talking about parts
of the Roman Empire that did not become
part of post-roman Europe and it's a
very important distinction because the
eastern parts the Roman Empire
particularly Egypt and Syria and Turkey
or Anatolia these were very prosperous
areas they were not overwhelmed by
Germanic folk my gracious or invasions
whatever you want to call them cities
remain prosperous coinage remain sound
business and manufacturing continued
none of these things were true of the
portion of the Roman Empire that we
think of us the Western Roman Empire
which comes to an end in the third
in the fourth quarter of the fifth
century so Christian Europe emerges
raises questions one possibility which I
think be interesting to explore if I
were to write a book and competition
with my own look would be to say why
don't we divide the west and the east
and take the history of the western part
of greco-roman antiquity that was say
the Western Roman Empire and the Muslim
and Spain say the Western possessions of
the Muslims and the old western part of
the Roman Empire and have a chapter just
on them and then have another chapter
that deals of the East that deals with
the mushrik the Eastern Islamic lands
along with Byzantium and and possibly
Kiev in Russia because of course one of
the things that's clear in both European
and Islamic historical traditions the
political traditions is that there's a
profound difference between eastern and
western Europe and a profoundest
difference between eastern and western
Islamic states and here I'm not
referring to the extensions of Islam
into India or Indonesia or down into
Africa but simply the middle east of
North Africa so you could group them in
that way now why wouldn't you do that
one reason you don't do it is that where
do you put the narrative of Mohammed and
the rise of Islam now you could say have
a chapter on Byzantium and Islam in the
East and then and tell the story of
Mohammed there in the story of
Charlemagne and now Charlemagne but of
Constantine and then tell the story of
Charlemagne
the conquest of Spain and so forth in
the subsequent chapter you could do that
but you know nobody does it and I think
the reason nobody does it that way
although in many ways it would make a
lot more sense is because it seems to
diminish the special character of Europe
so things you talk about you have as in
history one of 1931 chapter you know
lecture one actually first you have
something called the background of
European history for what you read and
were given the decline of all the Roman
Empire then you have the later Roman
Empire reading Thorndike's history of
medieval Europe then you have the rise
of the Christian Church followed by the
Germanic invasions and the Frankish
Empire followed by feudalism and serfdom
followed by the rise and spreadable
habit anism but just coming along
hundreds of years after its
chronological point then you have the
East and the Crusades you had to put the
muhammadans in there so that you could
explain the Crusades and then that's
last you hear the Muhammadans for a long
time then you got commerce and the rise
of towns the Holy Roman Empire the
making of France medieval England etc
etc so Europe is people are loath still
to to deconstruct Europe in terms of a
narrative and a lot of that arises from
the the interest in the Christian Church
the Christian Church
you know tacitly or implicitly should be
treated as a unity in the way that Islam
is treated other words it's it would be
wrong to divide Islam and it'll be wrong
to divide the Christian Church because
these are the great institutional and
ideological edifices of an era where you
had particularly in Europe deeply
divided a political territory and in the
Islamic world somewhat more unity but a
unity that broke down comparatively
early in the history of Islam so the
church and the Ummah the community of
Muslims seem to provide a central focus
but it's awkward to see it as a
narrative focus because the church and
Islam qua religion do not fit that well
a narrative approach by putting these
things in separate chapters Islam and
the rise of the church in separate
chapters it becomes it kind of overlooks
the fact that these two religious
traditions are phenomenally similar it's
phenomenally similar I have likened them
to Siamese twins separated at birth and
brought up in separate homes and they
hate each other but they are so so very
similar and the similarity is not
fundamentally doctrinal it's true that
all of all three have a doesn't say
Judaism Christianity and Islam because
the Jews have to be in there someplace
and they're very difficult to shoehorn
in you know you have to have stopped you
on the Jews but you know when you go st.
well the Jews it's awkward but
all three of these religions have myths
that go back to someone named Abraham or
Ibraheem so they can be talked about the
Abrahamic faiths for example but leaving
the doctrines aside you have
extraordinary similarities between
Christianity particularly in Western
Christendom and Islam that you don't
find if you throw all three literate
religious in together I've made this
argument in a book I published called
the case for Islamic Christian
civilization to my disappointment many
of my Jewish readers never got past the
title page finding it so offensive not
to be included or we see I think the New
York Times said good trick gratuitous
Lee and pejoratively excluded or
something like that you know how can you
how do you dare mention Muslims and
Christians and not mention Jews and you
really do have to read into the book all
the way to I think page 2 to get a
fairly explicit explanation of why
because I'm not writing about theology
or Scripture but rather about
institutional developments and the
institutional developments that are the
most interesting are those that have to
do with what the Europeans call a clergy
and what the Muslims call the Illuma
which is a plural of a word
eylem which means someone who possesses
ale which is the word for science or
concrete knowledge in other words it's
it is key entia
in Latin now in the medieval period L
was more often in this sense using it
plural
Illume meaning the the sciences and the
plural of the faith in other words you
know the notion of science was not the
modern notion of science but rather it's
the the concrete real and then doubted
knowledge that exists with respect to
with respect to the faith so an alum was
a specialist who had substantial
knowledge about the about Islam and the
plural there Lumad meant those people
who were these scholars are the
knowledgeable people in the Islamic
world and this word is used today still
the common word in in Arabic and Turkish
in Persian what we find more often is
where mullah and plural mullahs meaning
the the iranian clergy the word clergy
is avoided because muslim traditions are
very clear in their belief that not
having a formal a formally defined
clergy was a mark of superiority of
islam
so there are no monks in Islam there are
no clerics in Islam and there are no
mysteries seemingly like which a ritual
would confer a spiritual role upon
someone that was a a mystical role in
other words there nothing like the
ordination of clergy that empowered a
Christian clergymen to preside over a
mass in which be through the
intercession of the Almighty the bread
and the wine were converted into the
body and blood of Christ this this
miracle of the of the Eucharist the
conversion of the bread and wine into
the body and blood of Christ as the
central drama of of the Catholic Mass or
of the Christian mass prior to the
Reformation it really is of
extraordinary importance both Indians of
itself as a as a spiritual belief and
because it defined who could who could
do it if you had to be an ordained
priest so that kind of thing where you
have now you can have in a mosque
someone who serves giving the call to
prayer and he receives a salary someone
who serves as an imam who's the head of
the mosque and who leads prayers or
al-khatib a person who gives the noon
prayer on Friday you can have salary
positions of great prestige in
connection with mosque rituals but
they're they're not clergy there's no
there's no ordination and you can uh
swap these people out
and when you are in a mosque and the
Imam of the mosque stands in front and
you pray behind him it is no different
from if you are with a dozen friends in
a living room and you pray behind one of
these friends it's you know that there's
no there's no gift of the Holy Spirit
there's no divine or mysterious sanction
to this sort of thing so the clergy the
term clergy doesn't get used in Islamic
circles and therefore people think that
they are entirely different but of
course they're not they're remarkably
the same but the differences are are
interesting differences let me talk
about three first one is is the issue of
language you had a liturgical language
not to say a language used for Holy
Scripture and for the rituals of the
church or of the mosque but you had a
liturgical language on both sides Latin
in Catholic Europe Roman Catholic Europe
Greek and to a lesser degree Syriac for
the Eastern Orthodox Orthodox churches
and Arabic for for Islam these languages
were understood variously by their by
the bodies of believers who heard things
in them most Muslims have say at the
present day do not understand the Quran
when they hear it
recited because they're not Arabic
speakers and most of them have not gone
to a school to learn how to understand
the Quran and it has absolute
no no impact upon the degree to which
they can be moved and spiritually
uplifted by hearing the Quran recited
you know you don't you know you don't
have to know Italians who get all weepy
and Mimi dies and all that that blob om
you know the language is less important
than the in the context so you have
these languages that spread very widely
and clearly they provide a link that
defines difference civilizational or
different cultural you know areas Latin
defines Western Christendom Greek more
or less defines Eastern Christendom
although you have more variation there
and Arabic defines Islam some people
understood Latin or Arabic or Greek much
better than others but the notion that
you had a single language seems to be a
very important thing so in Europe Latin
dies
say in England by the early 1600s people
in Oxford and Cambridge the colleges
were still taught to read and write and
laughing but they were no longer taught
to speak Latin in 1400 you still have
people who spoke Latin if they have been
trained to do it but gradually the
notion of the Latin as a spoken language
dies and it is supplanted of course by
whole series of Latin eight languages
Romance languages and also my f series
of languages that are not rooted in
laughs and although they ended up having
very substantial Latin vocabularies a
Germanic Scandinavian Celtic languages
and and you think okay the division into
languages is sort of a vagary of
European history but people who are
really into European history all say now
that that's a really important vagary
because nations divide along the lines
of languages and when you come to to the
18th century and even more to the 19th
century the specificity of language as
opposed to the generality of language
becomes the core of nationalism and that
nationalism then becomes the the typical
ideology of the modern nation-state and
so in other parts of the world we should
see the same thing if Europe is a
template so is it natural for a
universal cultural language to devolve
into a group of different languages or
is that a very particular European
situation
and is it reasonable to take if it is a
particularly European situation is it
reasonable for a Benedict Anderson who
has written so much on language as the
the bedrock foundation of modern
nationalism is it reasonable to take
that as a as something that is a general
case that is to say that nationalism
will arise when you have these this
devolution of languages from a universal
tongue of Education refinement and
culture to a conjurer ease of separate
languages the idea that you can look at
language and say here is where
nationalism comes from comes a cropper
when you look at India which we haven't
haven't talked about in this context but
India had a universal language of
Education scripture culture and you know
higher attainments of all kinds of that
language of Sanskrit the Sanskrit
language undergoes the same thing that
Latin undergoes in Europe that is to say
you have a devolution of a Sanskrit
culture into a whole series of separate
languages that are derived from Sanskrit
and very very easily derived from
Sanskrit and yet not necessarily
mutually intelligible and be not
mutually intelligible and another set of
languages among people who use Sanskrit
once for scriptural and cultural
purposes but whose basic languages were
not derived from Sanskrit particularly
those people in southern India who speak
languages belonging to the Dravidian
family
so you would say well if if Europe is a
template in some way then when we look
at the at the language history of Europe
language history of India we should go
out with the same thing we should come
up with an India that's full of nation
states that have capitalized upon their
their linguistic identity because that's
what you got in Europe you know if it is
if it's a general phenomenon and some
people have have directly investigated
this this idea and being particularly of
professor at University of Michigan
Farina mirror who didn't dr. Aldus face
on Punjabi said there's Punjabi is
qualifies in every respect to be a
national language it it has a literature
it has a folkloric base it's broken in
dialects where the dialects are fairly
mutually intelligible it's concentrated
in a single region but it has never
given rise to a political a political
movement demanding a Punjabi state yeah
well is it a Punjabi state in Pakistan
or Punjabi state in India
well
no no well those are the six because of
the Punjabis are divided between two
countries India and Pakistan and three
religions Islam Hinduism and Sikhism now
there are certainly nationalistic
Punjabis but some of them are
nationalistic Pakistanis and some are
naturalistic India and some of them are
nationalistic Punjabis but they're not
pan punjabi in that respect that that's
coming out of the Sikh side of it anyway
this is the argument you made of the
book and I recommend the book to pursue
it further and just give me that as a as
an example of of where you can go in
asking whether language is truly
important
now you look if you were to take Europe
and Islam in comparison then you would
look at Arabic and you'd say Arabic
never broke down this would be wrong of
course because the colloquial Arabic
spoken in Oman or in Morocco or in
Lebanon or in Egypt these are not
mutually intelligible but they never
broke down in the way that Latin did in
two clearly distinct languages that that
became the core of national natural
identities or in modern terms of
nationalist ideologies classical Arabic
remains the standard remains what
everyone is expected to learn or claim
to learn it is the base of what is often
called modern Standard Arabic which
basically means modern Arabic has spoken
on Egyptian radio and television it has
to do more with the rise of radio and
television than it does movies than it
does with language but then you so then
you say okay Arabic does become the
basis of national
but it's the basis of pan-arab
nationalism all of us who speak Arabic
are one great big nation whereas the
Europeans never said all of us who come
from a Latin background are one great
big nation
you know we there was never a pan
romance unit people who spoke Romance
languages killed each other with
ferocity on remarkable frequency but
Arabic gets in gets sort of reinvented
as a as a basis for a nationalism that
has a sad and unsuccessful history
because essentially it was sort of an
impossibility okay language you know
it's a question is Europe typical as
Europe an example do is it necessary for
universal languages of culture of a
culture and learning to break down into
a into a Conger ease of gradually
separating languages will the English of
the 23rd century be spoken so
differently in India and China and the
United States and Brazil that they'll
form different languages I don't know
but people who have been dedicated to
European history kind of unconsciously
feel that Europe must be a model here
okay let's move to another area
celibacy this is a really really really
important thing
because Western Europe is - because
Europe is defined as the norm there has
been a tendency to to kind of not pay
very close attention to the absolutely
unbelievable bloodthirstiness of the
Romans no we say oh those Aztecs gee
they were awful they ripped hearts out
on Topsail Oh a terrible town and the
Romans no they were just ghastly now
really one of the most bloodthirsty
group of people that ever lived
it Mongols no doubt the Romans have
wheelstop read William Harris's book on
Roman warfare and you've got chapter and
verse on this but we tend not to focus
on that even though we we kind of like
to talk about the gladiatorial games and
the exhibits in the arena and and then
quote those brief passages from Romans
who say I was really disgusted by what I
saw in the arena today because they're
only a few people were disgusted and
everyone else is saying go lions go
lions it's uh you know so but we tend to
overlook that
now you can overlook it easily if you
say that European history starts with
the fall of Rome because then you can
skip gladiatorial games but what do you
do about celibacy well you know it it
isn't it isn't the instinctive game of
people to avoid sexual contact I I don't
think I'm saying something that's
inappropriate for a college classroom
but you know if it isn't the normal
thing on a comparative historical basis
you'll find that worldwide throughout
history almost every people has sought
to reproduce
not the Christian clergy at hourly stop
the Catholic clergy there are there been
any number of studies on this why
celibacy became the norm are not exactly
the norm it became the standard although
it was a standard that was violated
perhaps as often as it was observed
because you have continual messages
going out from from Rome through the
papal hierarchy saying try and get the
housekeeper out of father so-and-so's
mass I mean the the fact that you had
rampant sexuality when the clergy was
was known and by the time you get down
to the 18th 19th century it's not only
known was considered really kind of
kinky and you can write pornographic
works about nuns and priests and this
and that but but by and large as a
standard it had a huge impact and it's
been rather difficult Peter Brown has
probably written more about the issue of
of celibacy and where it comes from on
recent historians and it's tied into all
sorts of things relating to the body it
isn't just the celibacy of men and women
who have committed themselves to the
service of the church but it's also the
whole question of of the resurrection of
the body you know what is the you know
what is it about the body that is so it
is so important you had a one of the
Byzantine era philosophers in in
Alexandria maintained that when you went
to
paradise you got a spanking new fresh
state-of-the-art body you know you got a
cool new body you didn't have to be
stuck with that old body and and they
practically tore him apart for
maintaining that it wasn't the old body
you got and of course this had
implications that the body has to be
some will be buried together and then
you wonder see all my fingernail parings
over those many decades the hair that
was cut off to Lincoln do we get all
that back you know I don't know what
weight do you get what age are you going
to be these things were you know
fascinated European Christians and the
question of of the body was was tied
into to the question of of celibacy
celibacy did not have a place in Islam
it did not have a place in say the
Sanskrit religious cultures of India in
Islam you were expected to marry
celibacy was not forbidden and the need
we we know particularly from around the
1300s on that there is kind of an
increase in the number of people who
maintain a non married status although
and I've used that term non married
instead of celibate because in many of
these cases the biographical material
indicates that they had slave concubines
now they refrain from marriage but not
necessarily from all of the things that
come with marriage but quite a number of
them were also celibate but it was never
without prohibited
but it wasn't formally sanctioned so
what difference does it make if you have
celibacy of course if you have the idea
that being a member of the clergy is
involved with ordination or special vows
that set the clergy apart from other
people and that celibacy is one of the
key vows then you get the idea that the
clergy are not in society but they are a
separate society that the laity and the
clergy are separate this is something
that becomes very awkward when you look
at other societies you say well is it
normal for laity and clergy to be
separated in this in this fashion in
which the the clergy are felt to have a
spiritual role that in which celibacy
plays an important an important part in
the Islamic world you were expected to
marry in Eastern Orthodoxy you were
expected you were you were expected to
marry except for the people at the very
top of the church
what does an expectation but what the
celibacy imply institutionally well one
thing was that people who aren't doing
it don't go to the same parties as
people who are and there is the the idea
that the clergy should lead socially
separate lives where they will be among
people of their own attainment in terms
of subordinating the body to the spirit
that that comes to be a given first in
the form of people who go out and live
in the desert as Hermits or in small
groups but over time in the form of
monasticism in which the celibate monks
only some of whom which are priests most
of them are not priests but the
celebrate monks will live among
themselves and the celibate nuns will
live among themselves because the you
you just have different societies more
often than not being the monasteries and
the convents for nuns get built you know
on the margins or in even in the
countryside in other words they're not
put in the center of town there is a
matter of isolation frequently the
monasteries are surrounded by
agricultural land owned by the monastery
and worked by serfs who are also
basically owned by the monastery and who
are not celibate their labor either in
or serfs who do not have an oath of of
celibacy so you have an institutional
concomitant that you could argue would
not have been there if the clergy had
not had a
celibacy requirement so that it in Islam
it's frequently stated by Muslim
religious writers that there is no
monkhood in Islam annul minute no malice
Aries which is fairly true although
about absolutely perhaps but if the rule
of ah are marrying then they have to
live in society they have wives they
have children by large the ulama are men
a rare occasion you'll have a woman they
have wives children they have to support
themselves with businesses because they
don't for the most part derive an income
from their religious knowledge they own
property they carry on as ordinary
citizens they are different from from
the laity in the sense that the lay of
look to them for their greater knowledge
but not in the sense that they are
socially separate that they live in
separate institutions or that they have
a different life cycle deriving from
from their celibacy
corollary of this of this of course is
that you don't have the large number of
XS women that you have to deal with you
know if you take a substantial
percentage of your male population and
they are sworn to celibacy and their
going off and living in monasteries then
there are women who aren't going to get
married and what happens to them so the
the whole notion of taking women and
sequestering them in their own
institutions is something that has
virtually no parallel in the Muslim
world and it has consequences other
words when in the 1980s and 90s feminist
historians transformed the the narrative
of European history by discovering or
rediscovering perhaps the role of women
in European history many of the most
important figures that they focused on
were women who lived celibate lives as
nuns and in in nunneries and whose whose
poetry or writings were preserved
because of their particular role as a
Abbess of a nunnery or something like
that
so women's history becomes quite
different women's history and Islam as
in most of the world is enormous ly
complicated by the fact of marriage and
family life you know when you were
writing a textbook on world history and
your publisher says we want more about
women in country X you put in two
sentences saying women in this country
in this period were heavily involved
with with marriage and family life and
raising children and carrying out
women's duties within the context of a
marriage and house holding you don't
need to have any data to write that
since Institute you just kind of say
well hey that's that's what we could
safely assume nobody can prove it
it isn't true it isn't the same as
saying men killed animals and women grew
plants that's a very iffy proposition
but you know to say that women were
concerned with house holding and
children you know where's the downside
of that but but the fact of the matter
is if you know in Europe you can write a
women's history that is going to be far
more detailed and vivid and in some
respects uplifting than what you get in
other parts of the world because of the
because of basically the notion of
celibacy requires a sequestering of
women in women's societies where they're
where they will be encouraged to
to engage in spiritual and in some cases
intellectual and literary activities
when you so you know in the same way
that the question of language this
question of is Europe the norm on
language does language differentiation
lead to nationalism it's debatable then
this question of does is the European
model of women somehow a prototype for
for the world or is it something that is
that stands by itself because other
parts of the world don't have the same
traditions regarding women does the fact
that you have a division between clergy
and laity lead to a inherent struggle
say between a first estate of the
aristocracy a second estate of the
clergy and a third estate of the
bourgeoisie is that something that
emerges ineluctably out of out of the
European situation of separating clergy
from laity or is it a model for for the
rest of the world
you know finding common ground that gets
you someplace is I think very difficult
I tried to finesse it by inventing a
word Islamic Christian civilization or a
phrase okay I'll just say Muslims and
Christians one one civilization hue hue
and I'll throw you know rice from the
air or something like that and and then
see if I can google it five years later
and it swept the world and viral fashion
and everyone talks about Islamic
Christian civilization no it doesn't
work that way I thought it did but it
didn't instead what you have is a real
question as to whether anything that
happened in Europe follows or or puts
into place a model or a law or a process
that can or should be applied anywhere
else in the world
everyone congrat that Europe is special
because all the money ended up there at
one point and all the power ended up
there in one place there's no problem of
fat personal Mongols are the same thing
at another point but the question is
whether this specialness of Europe is
simply power and health or whether it
really is something that arises out of
the European political institutional
spiritual intellectual development in a
fashion that can be modeled elsewhere in
the world the
you know the period that this chapter
deals with ends in the year 1200 one of
the reasons for ending at that point was
that you come to the end of the Crusades
that is to say the Fourth Crusade occurs
in 1204 and
the Crusades you start in 1095 with a
preaching of the First Crusade at 96 and
you go to 1204 and you know the Fourth
Crusade there a spring and Crusades
after that but they don't about to a
whole lot and during this this period
you bring Islam in North Africa and
Europe and North Africa the Middle East
into direct conjunction with with
Western Christendom and to a lesser
degree with with Greek chrisandem the
tradition has been that the history of
the Crusades form a monumental chapter
in the history of Europe and that they
do not form a monumental chapter in the
history of Islam
and that that of course raises raises a
question what why were they so different
of course in any instance where you have
an invader and a defender you can argue
that the invader will always have more
stories going for him than the defendant
after all it was the the achans who
attack Troy and Troy - sat there and got
attacked and so we talk a lot more about
the Greek side than we do about the
Trojan side so they're a little bit of
that although we don't talk a whole lot
about the Japanese side in World War 2
but the but the Crusades have raised any
number of problems having to do with
whether they constitute a turning point
for the relations between Islam and and
Christian Europe and if so what kind of
a turning point now
there are several options that have been
adopted from the European side it's been
observed that the Crusades changed the
financial structure because people had
to borrow money to go in the Crusades
and because so many knights were killed
and it changed inheritance patterns it's
argued that it leads to a great rebirth
of knowledge as during that period many
works are translated from arabic into
latin like true it's argued that it's a
point where europe comes together and
europeans interact in a way that they
had not done previously it's a period of
military you know aggrandizement with
the building of castles and you know
knights and armors so forth and so on on
the Muslim side what is usually pointed
out is that when the Europeans came
Islam was comparatively weak that it
took a long time for it to muster its
its forces in a some sort of response
and that as a consequence the Crusaders
were were successful for a period of
time in establishing small
principalities in the Near East but that
basically there's there was little
residue that a little resulted from the
Crusades from the point of view of Islam
whereas a great deal resulted from the
point of view of Europe
in the last lecture I talked about
things that were happening in the in the
sort of the macro aspect of climate
change the Crusades take place during a
period of the freezing of the climate of
the Middle East of the northern Middle
East and a period of uncommon warmth in
Europe from the period of Crusades
onward Europeans become the dominant
traders and seafarers of the
Mediterranean and of the Atlantic and
Muslims who had previously been active
in that area or become of de ministry
importance the the question of whether
there is a a demographic shift
underlying these different perceptions
is the one I want to to get to because
what I argued last week is that the
population of the eastern let's say the
northern part of the Middle East Iraq
Iran Eastern Anatolia than to say the
eastern part of Asia Minor Byzantine
Empire seemed to have lost a tremendous
number of people in population starting
in the beginning of the 1000s Europe
appears to have gained enormous lis in
population starting at the same time and
seemingly both areas reacting to two
changes in the in the climatic situation
that then had impact
on the agricultural situations that they
were in so one of the possibilities here
is that the changes associated with the
Crusades of the European side are so
dramatic because they are simply a
political and military expression of a
new exuberance that Europe was
experiencing from reasons fundamentally
unconnected and Crusades and that the
the bland and unimpressive response of
the Muslims to the Crusades had to do
with the the great disjunction the
structure that was being caused by the
climate deterioration in the area so
that oh and there's one one crusading
chronicle talks about how on
such-and-such a day
an Iranian showed up on the battlefield
for the Muslims and he was so zealous
and he was such a devoted fighter that
he went out to battle and was killed
anything okay no hothead got killed
end of story and then you read the rest
chronic and he say that's the only
Iranian who came you know why was there
no army from the east when there had
been armies from the east for hundreds
of years before that why was no army
from the east mustered by the Caliph or
the other rulers of the east to fight
the Crusaders and of course I would
answer that they simply had not our
soldiers that they no longer had an
economy that was supporting a strong and
effective military regime
and that brings me to the - to the brink
of what I want to talk about next time
which has to do with longer term effects
of climate change and economic
rebalancing that's associated with it
and and the question as to whether those
effects and that rebalancing has more to
do with a kind of an automatic or
theoretically dictated series of
consequences as opposed to what's
appears to be that the the radically
path-dependent
outcomes that you get in areas connected
with religion and the clergy so I'll
stop here for today and pick this up on
Thursday